this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday April 26th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
last week we reported that Lyft plans to
lay off possibly more than 1200 workers
after already eliminating 700 rolls last
year
the company said it would announce more
details about the cuts tomorrow this
move comes days after a new CEO
officially took over and as the
ride-hailing company struggles to keep
up with its rival Uber so what's going
on with Lyft joining me to talk about
this is wsj ride hailing reporter Preeti
Karana pritika can you start by telling
us what do we know about these Cuts who
are they going to affect and why is the
company making them so we've reported on
Friday that the company was planning to
make another big round of cuts Lyft
issued a statement in response to our
story acknowledging that something is
coming but that it didn't say what all
that the company told employees was that
they could expect to know more on
Thursday meaning tomorrow our reporting
indicates it's going to be big 30 or
more of staff is what I'm hearing from
my sources so this comes as lyft's new
CEO is just stepping into the role let's
talk about this change of leadership can
you start by telling us you know why did
lyft's Founders step down so the company
has really been struggling for the last
year its stock price is down over 70
percent morale has been hard here it at
the company as it's been losing Market
shared Uber so employees were saying
look the co-founders have done a good
job of transforming a scrappy startup
into a household name but are they
really ready to take this to the next
level to lead a large public company and
that led to a lot of dissatisfaction
employees were asking the co-founders
about this at all hands meetings and a
lot of this also got to lift Sport and
there was increasing concern among
investors about the future of the
company so late last month both the
company's co-founders stepped back they
continued to remain on the company's
board but they said maybe it's time for
new leadership and Lyft has a new CEO
who officially took over last week so
tell us a bit about him who is he and
what's his vision for Lyft yeah so
lyft's new CEO David richer actually
served on the company's board for the
last 20 years he has actually run his
own non-profit but before that he held
senior leadership roles at Microsoft and
at Amazon and at Amazon I'm told that he
was very close to Jeff Bezos and that
people who did work with him at the time
enjoyed working with him it is an
interesting choice given that he comes
from the non-profit world I have met him
I have spoken to him since he got the
top job and he wouldn't give us details
but he says that his vision is to really
reinvent the way that Lyft treats its
writers the way that Lyft also treats
its drivers so he's going for a complete
overhaul what that involves remains to
be seen but he says he certainly has
plans to shake things up what's morale
at the company like now given that
they've gotten this leadership change
but also that these big cuts are coming
I think it's really mixed so on one hand
Lyft has really struggled over the last
year morale hasn't been good anyway a
lot of senior leaders at Lyft have
departed and now there's added anxiety
about whether they would have jobs with
these big cuts but on the other hand
there's also a sense of optimism and
excitement among some employees given
the new leadership some of them felt
frustrated that things were just moving
very slowly or barely moving at all
under the co-founders so there's a sense
that okay here's some fresh blood and
maybe things could take a turn for the
better what about Investors what are
they making of all these changes the
market has responded positively to the
change in leadership so when the
co-founders announced that they were
stepping down the stock actually went up
similarly when we broke the story about
more Cuts coming at Lyft the stock also
jumpedica can you explain to us why Lyft
is struggling so much to keep up with
Uber so one of the things things was
that Lyft decided not to diversify into
any other businesses during the pandemic
Uber of course had a food delivery
business now that wasn't a decision it
took during the pandemic but that
decision paid off in a big way that said
Lyft decided that it didn't want to
diversify during the Health crisis so it
stuck with its Transportation routes
even then
a lot of people say well if they did
stick their guns to Transportation they
should have owned that space that didn't
happen and then one of the other things
was and again this predates to the
pandemic but Uber has a global business
Lyft limited its presence to North
America Uber benefited in a big way
having global operations at a time when
the U.S was going through multiple
lockdowns and when the co-founders
stepped down one of the co-founders said
to me I asked him is there something you
regret and he says yeah the decision not
to take Lyft Global is something I
regret pretty good I wonder as somebody
who covers this space what is it going
to mean if Lyft can't keep up with Uber
and Uber's growth what is it going to
mean for U.S consumers and for
competition in the ride hailing space
already as Lyft stock has tanked over 70
percent over the last year there's been
a lot of speculation does someone buy
lift does the company become so
irrelevant that you only have one player
in the market and this is something I
asked the new CEO as well do you plan to
sell the company eventually if perhaps
things don't work out and he says for
now he doesn't have any plans to sell
the company his plan is really to get
back in the game he acknowledges that
they are a distant number two in the
market and he says the place that I want
Lyft to be for starters is a strong
number two because I don't want to have
one player he called it a 500 pound
gorilla that's how he referred to Uber
as he said I don't think it's good for a
500 pound player to dominate the entire
Market because choice is good
competition is good it helps everybody
okay that's wsj's pretty who covers ride
hailing thanks for joining us pritika
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]